is on the subject of celebrations today
as Vlad I'm sure knew it has a story
about uh it is international whiskey day
today and to celebrate that occasion and
also Mr GTA Mark Strassman traveled to
the oldest continuously operating
whiskey distillery in these United
States it's called the Buffalo Trace
Distillery even older than its home
state of Kentucky Mark learned about the
distillery's history and why when it
comes to whiskey age is more than just a
number
all right
[Music]
New Orleans has Bourbon Street
but this is bourbon habit I would like
to personally welcome you to the oldest
continually operated distillery in the
United States in Frankfort Kentucky tour
guide Freddie Johnson's toasting the
Buffalo Trace Distillery it's 1775
distilling Roots pre-date America itself
this is Warehouse J Mark Brown Buffalo
trace's president and CEO since 1997
finds whiskey drinkers to be famously
passionate whiskey fans will debate
whiskey the way sports fans will debate
their favorite players and teams correct
the richness of the topic
I think invites people in this just so
much that you can talk about
maybe You Don't Know Jack Daniels about
whiskey well bourbon is a type of
whiskey with a grain Mash made of at
least 51 corn
it's distilled fermented cooked and aged
in new charred Oak barrels for up to 25
years resting in warehouses like this
one Barrels in our house are just like
real estate location location location
it's a process
a collaboration between mother nature
and father time
what's left after years of rest finally
rolls out Barrel after Barrel ready for
the cork to be removed I gave it a shot
all right now you got it now I got it I
can work here that's a good one yeah
Buffalo Trace produces 250
000 barrels of whiskey a year including
its own brand and other big names like
Blanton's Eagle Rare Weller and Pappy
Van Winkle which sells for thousands of
dollars online
delayed gratification rules here
Executives have to project their Global
Market years in the future even today
what we're selling today we made that
decision in 2015 about what we were
going to make and today we're making
decisions about what we make for
2029. it's a challenging business that
way it is challenging yes in 97 so we
should make that much for
2005 and everybody was looking around in
2005 going what idiot didn't make enough
whiskey you were looking at the culprit
yeah thus the responsible party
since opening its warehouses in 1811
Buffalo Trace has built its
institutional knowledge one sip at a
time
even during prohibition it stayed open
legally one of four distilleries allowed
to make medicinal whiskey so it was us
three others in Al Capone
supplying the nation with all the
whiskey it needed who pulled off what
back then so there are a few questions
on a history we decided not not to ask
not to ask that being one of them
the mixture that you see right here
that is a straight Rock whiskey for more
than a century Johnson's family has
shared their history with the
distilleries three generations of
bourbon Whisperers starting with his
grandfather Jimmy Johnson Senior he was
the first African-American to be a
warehouse manager of a major Distillery
so I started playing around here when
I'm five years old what was that like
I was like Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory yeah I remember getting into a
lot of trouble yeah
I really think they were worried more
about the paperwork than they were about
me as a kid you know is it a story that
you're visiting has the largest
inventory of age Bourbons in the world
over the past few decades Johnson's been
keeping his family's Traditions alive
and has become the only tour guide ever
inducted into the Kentucky bourbon Hall
of Fame
it's no wonder guests travel near and
far to spend time with his whiskey
wizard
you're hoping they walk away with
I think one is an appreciation of
how the product that they've come to
enjoy gets created and
realizing as they walk away from here
that they have changed that their lives
have acts have been touched he's living
proof of an old joke among whiskey
lovers whatever the question bourbon is
the answer
for CBS morning's Mark Strassman in
Frankfort Kentucky
I'll toast to that